pour les usagers des transports publics
du centre les semaines se suivent et se
ressemblent le week-end n'a pas permis
de régler le conflit
au grand dam de l'association des
usagers ils se sont rendus chez le
préfet pour demander l'instauration d'un
service minimum mais ce dernier les a
renvoyés faire martinique transports ça
commence à
à bien faire c'est coutumier de la cft
urnes notamment donc les usagers autant
que moi parce que je suis aussi un
usager même si je suis la présidente je
le précise donc je suis impactés par ce
mouvement de grève
donc il serait temps qu'on se mettait
effectivement
autour d'une table toutes les parties
concernées pour mettre en place le
service minimum mais on va pas attendre
effectivement que
tout le monde discute sans fin parce que
ça peut durer encore très longtemps
syndicats et dirigeant de la cftc ont
décidé de s'en remettre à la direction
du travail pour déterminer si le
mouvement était une grève ou un droit de
retrait dans ce dernier cas les salariés
sont payés même s'ils ne travaillent pas
en grève
non comme nous le précise et une avocate
cette semaine le droit de retrait est
encadré le droit de retrait c'est le
droit qu'a le salarié de se retirer
d'arrêter son travail lorsqu'il estime
lorsqu'ils jugent qu'il y à un danger
grave et imminent
cette confusion entre le droit de
retrait et grève est peut-être l'une des
explications du nombre élevé de
mouvements à la cft eu l'association des
usagers a comptabilisé une centaine de
jours d'interruption cette année au
point que chez les financeurs on
commence à agiter le bâton
le conseiller exécutif de la ctm daniel
marie-sainte demande ainsi sur sa page
facebook
s'il faut maintenir les subventions en
cas de service interrompu